[Music]  alec baldwin and shia labeouf to  celebrities plagued by negative  publicity and hounded by the media are  announcing their retirement from public  life with a massive 48 City farewell  it's the Baldwin stop paying attention  to us tour sponsored by Quiznos he's too  shy withdrawn Hollywood actors want you  to respect their privacy in arenas all  across the country plus special  appearances by media victims and notable  introverts Chris Brown Miley Cyrus and  every show on the tour ends with a  spectacular please respect our privacy  fireworks extravaganza and don't forget  to ask about our special VIP meetin beat  for just $2,000 you can attempt to  photograph alec baldwin while he shoves  you against the wall this will be your  last chance to see these two celebrities  in public before they take their toll  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]